three-two-one
main review mean review the legend
Johnny be you'll find a little did a
cover better than Eminem better than
original for real people ask me all the
time Felix what is your favorite meal
what is the snack that you eat before
your videos to get you that edge and I
always say tide pots
type odds are delicious they are so
tasty the salt savory moist dry all
these components just packed into a tide
pot it is so good now they came out with
a hot pocket Tide Pods and I gotta say
I'm now this is not hashtags bonds but I
wish because it is delicious the crust
of the hot pockets containing the savory
of the Tide Pods it really hits your
stomach in a way that I came even begin
to explain it's not just me that loved
Tide Pods of course squid would another
famous east celeb loves loves type pups
even spongebob loved Tide Pods there's
even Mexican style
there's even Mexican style Tide Pods
which I haven't I haven't tried yet but
I can only imagine that you don't need
it you clearly don't need any other
condiments in there cuz that's that
looks good by itself he also got there
doc Tino's pizza roll detergent those am
sorta like an off-brand Tide Pods but
nevertheless still probably very
delicious give up your seats to someone
carrying something more important that's
right if you see a pregnant lady
carrying a type on you need to let her
stay
and take your spot excuse me I didn't
know you were pregnant with a tide pot I
am so sorry please have my seat don't
judge me but Tide Pods are delicious and
basically I just ate 47 of them damn
that's a lot of time pods I don't think
I have ever eaten that many type buds
people cooking Tide Pods just sharing
well what is the best way to enjoy a
time no more eating xanax in 2018 we eat
in Tai pods from now on that's right now
if you don't get the joke somehow it
became a meme that you're supposed to
eat Tide Pods and we have all these
websites like BuzzFeed and Mashable
saying don't don't eat Tide Pods and I
feel like I should say that too but
they're just so delicious some people
some haters in the tide pod community
says that it's toxic
[Music]
or you could die Oh clearly these people
don't know the great word of the tied
punch and how delicious they are
now the original this means some people
speculate is from the onion supposed to
two years ago but recently got a lot of
traction for whoever the [__] knows what
reason I can't believe I have to say
these but please don't eat Tide Pods I
guess you want them all for yourself
Mashable don't think I'm onto your game
I'm even matching my outfit with bad
puns step up your [__] bet you wish you
were a tight part cuz I wish that every
night please God make me into tight pod
someone some brave soul road to gushers
than kami Brandon asked hear me out
there was a fruit snack that looked like
a laundry pod not any specific branded
one because you know legality but what
if it looked like a laundry pod we all
want to eat them so bad thanks for your
time I hope it takes up and they blocked
her disgusting we also have tied punch
and probably the most beautiful being
ever created in this universe and sorry
Marcia type odd Chan wins every time
tied punch and here we have a furry
account enjoying some type odd Pete set
look at that Wow happening having a
great time look having it that looks so
good I feel jealous then a but at the
same time it's wonderful it's wonderful
that people share their own recipes I
feel sick we even have famous chefs like
Gordon Ramsay delicious finally some
good effing food I haven't been eating
my whole life until I discovered Tide
Pods when you're listening to someone
speak and you can feel your type but so
go for
share the time pod the great wisdom no
longer it would be a secret for the
unknown share the time pod with a friend
how the spank about time pod type on
meme is a solid 8.1 I would say it could
even get to attend him if someone dies I
think someone needs to die for a meme to
to get to 10 out of 10 you know what I
mean
next me please thank you you know we're
gonna talk about logan paul memes
everybody they're fresh they're hot and
they're gonna burn out fast seeing is it
man
logan parlors yo you alive we have the
say ori hanging meme and logan paul
reacting to it horrible despicable i
can't believe he did this
literally anything hanging logan paul
just can't help himself he has to react
to it there's just too much click baton
thumbnail how could you do that logo how
could you do that
Yoda watching sacred sacred text burn in
the last Jedi 2017 colorized we have
Logan Paul playing the famous game the
forest local plod reacting to poor poor
Karma
what did it Kermie to ever do Logan you
don't have goddamnit
well someone stop Logan when your friend
asked if you want to hang out
that was good meme here's a look at Paul
reacted to spongebob hanging Logan
please understanding that suicide is
real a big issue and usual platform to
make awareness for it
clickbait suicide for money and views
well done Logan [__] someone pointed out
that there on the trending page we have
Logan Paul and the second training one
was man of the woods
everyone is just click baiting these
days they can't help themselves
look at Paul that's jontron please Logan
stop it stop reacting to all the bad
memes the sayonara set suppose sensei
Logan Paul really now I'm gonna have to
put my foot down and say oh I am
officially challenging you in the
bathroom now the beautifulness of the
Logan Paul meme is that the moral high
ground of the me it's not making fun of
suicide it's making fun of how stupid
Logan Paul is I'm gonna rape this mean
to seven and a half do we do fight a
third person in the suicide forest it's
it's a meme where everyone can just get
on board well Logan Paul fan or not
everyone likes to laugh but a stupid
thing oh look he make a mistake good
thing I never make any of those I'm
fearful but the mean will run out past
it's gonna burn out fast I better get
this video up a s P but I think in a
couple months from now on we'll still
see the Logan Paul face appearing
somewhere else that's sort of relatable
maybe maybe we'll turn into a nice
little crossover meme in the future the
future will tell us all about this now
we have time for one more
meme can I get it
lucky we have time for bonus me this
means special time for everyone it's the
okay sign me I don't get this mean I
don't I don't get it we never played
this game when I was young but
apparently if you do the upside-down
hand sign and you make them look at it
you're supposed to catch them off-guard
like hey buddy look at these you get the
punch in that it's a call the circle
game what the heck is what is this what
I don't understand it's just kind of
annoying let's play the charcoal game
sucker
nice little meme generator dotnet here
I'm rating this meme a zero that's right
the first zero on meme review I hate
this me it's so stupid
I hate it so much ever noticed that
Italy is shaped like a boot